what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while she's
trying to get rich for us let's just
trying to get a lunch money right i'm
here with the beautiful intelligent
planet eviluva marinova
she's wearing a librarian sweater today
look how great it looks
yeah looking like a nerd looking like a
nerd a
nerd it's fine hey everyone's gotta go
to the library sometimes and read
library nerd that's fine don't forget
that much money is now sponsored by
block five block five allows you to earn
up to eight point six percent apy in an
interest bearing account
go and get an account at block five
block five is awesome i'm an investor i
sit on the board
they are growing real
fast like a rocket ship bitcoin is like
a rocket ship the first stop is getting
on board with block five do your
research go and get a blockfly account
blockpy.com
come and join us in the revolution
first of all thank you guys for coming
and liking my youtube channel
and my video and my interview unless
you're paying we ain't running your ads
let's go
i am paying so um the first topic is
bitcoin
bitcoin today has surpassed
12 000
it has it's a 12.7 no 12
700 hey i ain't going to say
that i told you so you know i ain't
going to say
i'm going to take my victory lap when
this thing pops over 20k at some point
but i am going to say that i did say
that we were going to see interest rates
cut that we were going to see printing
of money it was going to simultaneously
occur around the same time as the
bitcoin having and that was going to
lead to
[Music]
what's most surprising to me about
bitcoin is that in recent days i've met
a lot of surprising people that you
would never think
don't say names i'm not that you would
never think would own
bitcoin and they're big bitcoin people
and i'm just
surprised why it's like the secret
bitcoin balls
sound money everybody knows either you
got that
unsound money or you got sound money you
want real sound money
hard money you want the hardest money
the world's ever seen
you know where to find it you want that
flimsy stuff
that stuff that can get printed out of
thin air knock yourself out go hold that
other garbage
paypal plans to allow customers to buy
cryptocurrency through their accounts
and use cryptocurrency for merchant
payments this is huge the company
announced wednesday that is
introducing a way for customers to buy
hold and sell certain cryptocurrencies
within the paypal
wallet this will roll out over the
coming weeks
dots this no-brainer 300 something
million people use paypal they got 25 26
million
merchants uh this is big because they're
going to allow you to buy sell or
purchase with bitcoin and then they also
announced that they're going to bring
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies to
venmo in 2021
hello mass adoption ah been
telling y'all so two years ago okay stop
it
two years ago when i was at fortune um i
uh wrote a so dan shulman the ceo of
paypal came into the office and we got
to interview him
and so this was right right around the
time where uh paypal
pulled out of libra which was facebook's
uh cryptocurrency project so i asked
them i was like does this have anything
to do with the fact that
you guys want to do something on your
own because like no comment like i don't
want to comment on this whatever
but then i asked him do you personally
own any cryptocurrencies
and he said yes bitcoin and i said only
bitcoin
and he said only yes you can find my
article
on fortune.com it's dan shulman paypal
paulina
because we got a bitcoiner running
paypal
they're everywhere it doesn't matter you
can walk down the street
bitcoiners you can go home bitcoiners
you can literally go to work
bitcoiners they're everywhere you know
why because they're intelligent people
who have done their work and understand
the beauty and benefit of sound money
guys
he's wearing he wore his fancy hoodie
for you today to tell you this
we popping in the bitcoin world
goldman sachs speaking of non-bitcoiners
is going to pay 2.8 billion and
dollars and admit wrongdoing to settle
the 1
mdb charges do you want to remind us
what the 1mdb was
if you've read the book or listened to
the audiobook of
billion dollar whale the story of joe
lowe basically they
uh goldman sachs helped this fund in
malaysia raise a bunch of money it was
fraudulent
uh there's a lot to say that maybe
people knew that it was fraudulent but
they still helped them raise it he ended
up taking a bunch of that money
and he disappeared uh a lot of people
think he's in china now
but during his time between raising the
money and disappearing
he basically spent a ton of money he
bought jets he bought real estate he
financed the wolf of wall street movie
like he was doing everything
everything prosecutors have accused an
in
international cast of characters
including two goldman bankers of
embezzling billions of dollars from the
fund
and u.s officials had been preparing a
case the bank ignored signs of fraud and
pursuit of fees
never ignore signs of fraud all i will
say on this one
is usually they don't admit wrongdoing
but paying a 2.8 billion dollar fine end
admitting wrongdoing
i don't know what's happening it's
definitely not grown of ours all right
okay the pandemic is speeding up
automation
and 85 million jobs are on the line
every trend that was already underway is
just getting accelerated
that's what i was going to say uh
they're saying automation
in tandem with the covid19 recession is
creating a double disruption scenario
for workers
uh a report by the world economic forum
said
basically for the first time in years
job creation is starting to lag behind
job destruction
and this factor is poised to affect
disadvantaged workers with particular
ferocity one positive development on
this is that
new business applications are up 40
year-over-year new business applications
yep
in the united states and so business
applications yeah like
businesses applying to to start a
business uh
and so hopefully that will lead to a
creation of more jobs but it has
definitely slowed in the
past all right let's go next topic i'm
happy to talk about
star this company raises four million
dollars to help online collaborators
split revenue
guess who is an investor
it says individual investors include
creator economy and fintech heavyweights
including patreon ceo
youtube co-founder anchor ceo youtube
personality casey neistat
other investors and why are you not
under individuals
other investors include stripes head of
business development
creator anthony probably l-o-o-l-l
creator economy expert joe you're a
legend for that one
who's joe the ceo and the co-ceos of
brex
of rex oh i interviewed them so
uh all these creators they are basically
the modern small business
and small businesses need software to
run their business all the financials
all the kind of things that it takes to
actually run the business
has to be built a lot of the existing
software whether it's tax or finance or
whatever
isn't built for these types of
businesses so a great example is
uh what happens if paulina and i are
both creators and we create a youtube
video we put it on youtube
uh and then all the revenue from that
video i get because it's my
channel and then she has to trust me to
send it to her et cetera well now all of
a sudden you can do a simple thing like
you can select that video and say all
the revenue derived from this one video
as youtube goes to pay it out it'll get
split on a pre-agreed upon
uh percentage so i get 60 because i'm
cool she gets 40
because she's not and then every time
youtube goes to pay us it automatically
splits it for us
you can also imagine things like um you
know hey i gotta pay my manager
i'm gonna pay my agent i gotta do this i
gotta do whatever it's all just using
software to automate this and make the
finances
nobody has to trust anyone yeah i'm a
big fan of no trust
so okay what's next there is four
million dollars homebrew
uh who who else uh ludlow ventures
me casey neistat chad hurley
i said it yeah okay baller group i'm
nasty
ian borthwick had to shout out my friend
okay do you have any more friends to
shout out
a nasa spacecraft on tuesday touched the
surface of the asteroid
bennu in a mission that aims to return
rocky pieces for examination
to earth oh my god we never saw the
dinosaur
come on rio i got things to do okay my
t-rex
it was it was on display and i just
remembered um
the mission marks the first time nasa
has attempted to return materials from
an asteroid
while nasa confirmed that the spacecraft
touched the asteroid
the space agency will not know for
several more hours if it collected the
materials successfully
that is so cool remember that game we
used to shoot the asteroids in the video
game
that's basically what they're doing here
but they're instead of shooting them
they're
sending these things to land on so they
move so fast how are we landing stuff on
something moving 25 000 miles per hour
are we going 26 000 miles an hour and
like coming in front are we just like
shooting the cable and pulling us to it
on a webcast
nasa said touchdown declared sampling is
in progress
i've always wanted to say that houston
we have a problem that's not what they
said
i know but that's the most so that's
really cool right i do like the fact
that uh
the uh acronym for osiris
rex is origin spectral interpretation
resource identification security
legal life explorer that's the name of
the nasa spacecraft
it's kind of like t-rex rex whatever
just the fact that we're landing stuff
on asteroids
you know it's like if you ever played
nba 2k when you were a kid
and uh you would get hot you hit two
shots like he's heating up
and the third one that he's on fire and
then every time down the court you could
just shoot
you can just shoot from anywhere that's
nasa right now nasa's he's heating up
we got the uh humans and there's still
an asteroid that's supposed to hit the
us on november
nasa
i was kidnapped by mimes once
good don't come back no they did
unspeakable it's things of like a
dirty chair no it's not unspeakable
lines
this is a kid's show i don't know if
that was that was you're so annoying
kids get your minds out of the gutter
gonna tell the kids so the parents don't
have why is your little tie so
short but the other one's so long here
because i'm uh
oddball so easy big laugh all right guys
that's it for lunch money i got [ __ ] to
go do
have a great day bang bang hope you guys
enjoyed this episode of lunch money as
much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends